the spider-man far from home trailer is
about to play but if you haven't seen
Avengers end game yet stop watching
because there's some serious spoilers
about to come up but if you have seen
Avengers end game enjoy the trailer
where I go I see his face I miss him
yeah I miss him too I don't think Tony
would have done what he did if he didn't
know that you were gonna be here after
he was gone
you gonna be in next autumn and now well
no I don't have time I'm too busy doing
your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm kidding
look keep up the good work because I am
going on vacation
heads up Nick Fury's calling you I don't
really want to talk to me at all why
because if you don't talk to him a knife
to talk but I want to talk to him
you sent Nick Fury to voicemail I gotta
go you do not ghost Nick Fury
Dierks what's up we're just talking
about the trip I'm here in San Marco
Polo's oh I think MJ really likes me
there was B when I first went alone
you're a very difficult person to
contact spider-man
this is mr. Veeck you can use someone
like you on my world new world Beck is
from earth just not out the snap to our
hole in our dimension job to do
you're coming with us
it's gotta be something else you can use
what about Thor offworld captain
unavailable from your neighborhood
spider-man [ __ ] please you've been to
space what do you want Peter I want to
go back on my trip with the girl who I
really like and tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not
I mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die putting my friends
- Dana
the world needs Next Iron Man
you're going to step up or not
[Music]
here building jet I work with spider-man
do one for spider-man
I want wet spider-man not for spider-man
you
[Music]